Marco gebardi from University of Buffalo
is gonna tell us about bills
differentially private algorithms
effectively and with guarantees that
they actually do what you're asking
thank you all right so thanks first of
all to the organizer for having me here
it's a pleasure to speak here and I hope
I will show you something interesting
during these three hours so I think I'm
the only person here or maybe not I see
other person other people that do a bit
of formal method but I'm definitely we
are a very few of us but I think a
formal methods are very important for
what we are trying to do for trying to
build a correct application application
that respect the privacy and I'm happy
to be here and present some of our work
so Jonna recommended me to prepare a
mini course and not only a tutorial so I
tried to structure my three-hour in a
kind of mini course and the idea is one
you see here so in the first part I will
give you an introduction to formal
methods I'm not sure if everybody know
what formal methods are or maybe you
just have a rough idea I want to give
some common vocabulary some common
understanding of what formal methods are
and why they can be useful in this
setting and then I will focus on one
particular kind of application that
people have developed in terms of
languages and system support in
differential privacy while in the second
part I will focus more on formal
verification which is the idea of
proving
our implementation correct so in the
first part I will focus more on support
for differential privacy while in the
second part more proving that our
application are correct and then I will
try to finish in the third part with
some other direction that people are
looking at and also trying to give you
some pointer for some potential
interesting question that we can discuss
during the semester I think for me the
ideal would be to add some of you bring
your own expertise and try to help with
formal methods or vice versa trying to
use formal methods for some problem you
are interested in to answer other some
interaction during the semester alright
so one thing that I should mention
before starting is that I will show you
I will not show you many mathematical
formulas because this is not what we do
but I will show you a lot of code so I
will try to walk through the code as
lowly but I think is important if the
code is not clear that you stopped me
and we try to understand it better the
code will be quite simple not too
complex code but I will have a lot of
examples so I think is important really
that we make this a bit interactive all
right so let me start with a brief
high-level introduction of what formal
methods are so the general idea is
always difficult introduce a big area
like formal methods but the general idea
I think that we can have about formal
method is that we usually face the
problem of designer algorithm and we
proved that these algorithms and good
properties but at the end of the day we
need to have this algorithm implemented
in some system or language
that can do the job like as we as a
sincere was mentioning the census is
going through the effort to implement a
theory that we know into a practical
application and we in general want
webson guarantee that this is done in a
good way and the formal methods try to
make this process as a mathematically
rigorous as possible so is a collection
of technique to take an idea and bring
it to an implementation in a
mathematically rigorous way so in other
term what is the goal of formal method
this building application that are
correct giving you some confidence that
what is implemented is correct
now why correctness matters I hope I
don't have to make this too explicit
here but in general we wanted to add
correctness because we want to avoid the
critical failure we don't want that we
implemented all our application and then
we don't have the property that we
expect this has happened in many
situation from this financial system to
self-driving car to as I put here some
rocket that adds an a software problem
and this created some failure and we
don't want this to happen
also for differential privacy we don't
want that something that we claim is
differentially private in the end is not
now what do we mean by correct I think
this is one of the main issue that often
we face when we try to interact with
people outside our field so it's very
important for us make clear what the
notion of correctness means
for instance we are interested in
differential privacy and this is a
mathematical formulation of what we
expect from our algorithm and is a
formal enough definition in general we
interpret this kind of requirement as
specification that our system had to
meet and we have two kind of
specification in general one that we
call the usually functional
specification that is more about what is
computed and another kind of
specification which consider
non-functional aspect how this is
computed for instance we may in
application for instance two autonomous
vehicle we may want to have some strict
requirement intent in terms of reaction
to some action now the problem is that
what correctness mean is not only is not
always easy to formalize so if we take
again some application like the one that
nowadays are hot like autonomous driving
or like some software for recognition
and so on what do we mean here by
correctness is difficult to formalize
the notion itself of correctness and
this is why people often relies not on
formal methods but more on some
empirical evaluation of correctness so I
want to distinguish this situation from
what we are trying to address what we
try to address is a situation where we
can specify what our program is supposed
to do in contrast with just doing some
empirical evaluation now last slide to
try to convince you why correctness is
important I want to mention one project
that was I think a quite successful in
showing
the usefulness of formal methods so
DARPA the a challenge for trying to
protect the drone from arcing it was a
challenge where they were asking to some
team who are some drone and before any
the original drone was easy a cabal so a
group of hacker were able to enter the
system and take control of the drone
quite quickly but then the Challenger
was to improve this system and avoid the
further I can endure it amend that team
from the formal metal side fully
formalize the main part of the software
that the drone use and as a result the
the drugged a team of Acker was not able
to access the drone software anymore now
this is not of course a mathematical
proof this is more of an empirical proof
but I think it tells us something we
tell us that if we pay attention on now
we design our application how we make
sure that they satisfy some property we
can guarantee the absence of some bugs
that usually are water we can exploit
for instance in security application ok
any question on the general picture all
right now
I said that correctness is important but
its correctness easy to determine in
general because maybe is easy to
determine and maybe we are trying to
develop tools that are not useful and
maybe I'm just wasting your time with
this so let me try a small test is this
a simple program correct
so I hope at the program is a
self-explanatory is a basic program is
let let me try to read it I use a a kind
of pseudocode I think most of you should
be familiar with something like this so
is a function that has a variable R
which is initialized to 0 then a
variable n which is initialized with one
of the parameter Y and then it loops
until n get to 0 and it does R equal to
R plus 1 and n equal to n minus 1 and
then a return are yes no no good is not
otherwise I would not show it Y is not
that's a that's exactly one of the
important point we don't know actually
if it is correct or not but something
yes something something fishy is going
on and why why something fishy is going
on because this function is called ad
the so we expect that the programmer
wanted to implement an addition function
but then the variable R which is the one
that in the end we return is initialized
to 0 and if we look at the loop here we
just increment it and we incremented
mainly accordingly to Y so the result is
just Y so something seems wrong but as a
one of you pointed out what is wrong
here is the name or the program right
and the dissolution is what you suggest
that then these we need to do give the
specification and say what we want to
compute now these are of course is a
simple program and let's assume that the
specification is what the name suggests
the so that this function should compute
the addition now unfortunately just
adding this condition is still not
enough why is not enough what can go
wrong condition on x and y exactly
because otherwise for instance we may
give a negative number and never it 0
and so this program would run forever
but for the next slide is close to the
one for exiting the presentation I will
try to avoid doing this and more so we
can add also a precondition usually we
call them preconditions and
postconditions a precondition that tell
us what we expect from the input and if
we don't meet this precondition with the
run the program at all B
is a kind of contract that we expect
with that an interface that we expect a
programmer to use to run our program but
under this precondition we want to
expect we want that the dispersed
condition to be valid so now that we
have a formal specification we can ask
yourself does this program comply with
the specification and since we said that
we want in addition we can see that it
does not fail to meet this specification
okay
why it failed to meet this specification
because if we give X which is not 0
let's say X to be 2 the result will just
be with just not account for these two
it will be just the Y okay yes
if you program language doesn't have
stop typing we think of those as
preconditions as well yes no no no so
thanks for the question
it helped me it reminds me something I
wanted to say it so although I'm a
formal method person in this
presentation I tried to avoid as much
formalism as possible so I will try to
be a bit informed so in particular i I
will use a bit precondition and promise
condition in general but I will also use
types in some place but what I want to
give you is more like the overall
feeling of how to do these things and
now I will not go in the technical
detail of different solution so you can
think about these also as types or you
can think of adding the type constraint
that will be the same any other question
okay so once we have the specification
we can try to see if our program
guarantee it or not and in general we
can have a different kind of
specification in this case the
specification is quite precise it's only
about the functional aspect we don't say
anything about how to compute it we
don't add for instance any requirement
on the time that this function should
take over the memory that it uses but is
quite precise on the functional
specification now
this is a general idea that this is the
basic we need the formal specification
and then we can develop a tool to see if
our program meet the specification or
not and that may be to help a designer
to guarantee that the program meet the
specification now the formal method area
is quite wide and I try to think about
some way to compare the different formal
methods and I came up with this free
direction I think this will be useful a
bit later in my talk when we will see at
a technique for differential privacy now
what I realized is that this 3d plot is
a good to just give the overall idea
when I will start what the point is not
clear in which direction we are going
but I will say this specifically so what
are these three direction so one of them
is a usability so one of the reason why
formal method has not been widely used
is that they don't come for free no
formal method come for free if you want
adjust to have the same boredom you have
just by programming then you cannot use
any formal method if you use formal
method you need to learn something new
you need to learn how to use them but we
is not something discrete we have
methods that are more usable and method
methods that are more usable and methods
that are less usable so this is a
certainly one of the direction another
direction is the expressivity is how far
we can go in verifying our example I
show you a tiny example before but can
we verify something like the application
of their sensors can we really verify
something big
another direction is the granularity of
the enforcement now this is maybe not
clear now and it will become more clear
later is how how far we go in the
verification in the sense of our fine
grain we go in the verification are we
in play are we verifying just an eye
level algorithm an eye level program or
we are verifying at the old software
infrastructure because of course maybe
we have something that is differentially
private on paper or at the eye level but
then maybe the implementation at the low
level is not differentially private so
this is another direction that I think
is important
if we keep in mind this free direction
how can we guarantee that the program
meets the specification now I will try
to look at free different direction in
my talk so the first one that was also
the first one that came up in the
differential privacy literature is
trying to design a language or a system
which guarantee split the specification
the property of interest by design so I
write my program and I trust the
developer of this programming language
that I'm doing something that meet the
specification and this will be mainly
the first part of my talk then in the
second one we will look at how to
formally verify that the program in the
specification and finally I will also
try to in that testing that a program
meets specification this is not misses
is not usually considered formal method
because we don't have a guarantee which
is 100% but is a more statistical base
guarantee where we can say that on a
certain coverage of our code that we are
quite convinced that the program meet
the specification and of course I will
try to look at these three approaches in
the case of differentials any question
yes the background how different are the
methods he is here than hardware
verification that's a good question so
yeah so the first the first part I would
say is very different because I usually
actually not I take it back is the first
part is very similar to languages that
have developed to specify are blur so
often they support some kind of
verification there is an old branch of
computer supported design for hardware
and this is similar to the first part
the second there has been some attempt
especially by Intel for instance in
developing formal methods in that sense
of formal verification for verifying
hardware and I think they are quite
similar method but they for instance
they don't care too much about
probabilities thing that is a needed for
differential privacy so the technical
detail are quite different and also
testing is a very well developed for
hardware the reality is that both for
software and hardware probably testing
is what is more used in deployment of
software or hardware
designing a language system yes so
that's exactly the job of formal methods
people designing new languages so now in
general I would say that maybe I said
designing new languages but what I
really mean is designing new approaches
so not necessarily one specific language
but a family of languages that can
support the specification for instance I
was mentioning now hardware designing
people are the people that work on
hardware design have developed languages
that are specific for this task and
these are very different from C or
Python or R because they are a domain
specific to their need so you have
supported to design circuit that you
don't have in general programming we can
think also like statistical software as
a domain-specific in this sense
following on house but she just
understand the set of them it if this is
a new language or system can it then
test the languages that I use I mean so
instead to the program that's evaluated
doesn't have to be the same so yeah so
that's a very good question so in
general like we can think about these
languages as independent from other
application but this is not the only
approach we could also think about
synergy with other Toula so for instance
we could imagine that I can write in my
Python usual environment and I use some
primitive that has been designed with
the other languages so it doesn't need
to be completely done in these new
languages it's not that we need to
forget everything else we will see in
few slides I mean of course the
languages are not famous I think except
in this community but yes I will give
you okay so we focus on differential
privacy I think I don't need to go
through the definition again all of you
now should know it but one thing that I
want to point out is that something that
made me struggle a lot at the beginning
when I entered this area of formal
verification of differential privacy is
that this definition talk about privacy
but then me
there is no mention to other property
that we usually want and I remember
still one of the first discussion I had
with Kobe saying but this program a bla
satisfied differential
privacy and can't be said not really
because it has no accuracy so it was a
like a trivial example where where the
program was not computing anything
interesting and that made me understand
that is true that there are example that
respect this definition but maybe I
think what what you really meant is
actually you were drinking but the
coffee I don't know if you have a
strange reduction to coffees but they
think of what you actually meant is of
course it respect this definition that
is not something we usually want to
consider we don't even need to think
about this kind of example because it
had it was almost useless so these to
say that I think in general when I talk
with you guys you don't have only
privacy in mind but you have two other
dimension that are important to account
one is the accuracy of the analysis and
the other is the efficiency of the
analysis so for me a program that ran in
exponential time and is differentially
private is perfectly fine in the sense
that it respects the previous definition
but on the other end that this is a
probably useless so in some sense what
I'm trying to say is that although we
have a formal definition of privacy in
practice you you're a designer of any
use also some definition of accuracy and
efficiency that we need to consider and
I think in general we need to think
about this as a correctness not only
privacy but all these properties
okay let me motivate one last time why
we care about this in the context of
privacy so we may wonder if correctness
matter for differential privacy and we
can just look at some of the thing that
went wrong for differential privacy and
try to understand if we are at risk as a
general as an other software so I think
one example that we use a lot motivate
our work is this example of a sparse
vector I think that some of you have
already seen this several time I
apologize for this all right so for the
people that didn't see this light before
so these are six variational of this
perspective technique that where that
appears are now somewhere in the
literature and three of them are not
differentially private and the problem
is that are a small variation and it's
difficult to detect directly if they are
differentially private or not and they
will come back on sparse vector later in
my talk but I think what I want to
stress here is that this variation were
not proposed by people that have no
knowledge of privacy these were proposed
by people of the community people that I
trust and I am sure all of you sorry
people people that I know but that was
the good one yeah but I think people
that we should trust but is just the
problem that also people that can be
trusted
sometime commitments
is a human committing mistakes and so we
need to take to try to avoid these
mistakes but the way to avoid it is not
just by not trusting these people and
more but trying to give them some way to
support their claim and so I think the
work we are doing get goes in this
direction another example I think some
of you are familiar with this work by
India who showed a naive implementation
of the Laplace mechanism is not
differentially private an a/b
implementation on floating using
floating point number is not
differentially private and the reason is
that we can use the irregularity of
floating point number to reconstruct the
secret now is the attacker was on a
small scale but as Kobe said this week
we should be careful because even attack
on the small scale if we want we can try
to put them on a large scale I don't
think there was a real effort here to do
it on a large scale but I do not I'm
quite confident that this could be put
on a large scale and by the way most of
the implementation don't take care of
addressing these this attack which I
think telescopes or something about
people that are trying to deploy in
differential privacy although we know
that there are a bad situation they
somehow the cost that I was talking
before the cost of trying to address
this situation is sometime something
that people don't want to afford alas
the example of how things can go wrong
is even if we implement things in
the good way we need to be careful with
a usual problem that we were not only in
differential privacy but in many
security application which are possible
attack doing for instance two side
channels and for instance some people
that made an attack on some of the
languages I will discuss about these on
timing attack and this was although some
of them took care of high level timing
channel at the low level looking at the
floating-point implementation again
these people were able to do an attack
so we need to be careful and this is
also trying to give you the idea why
having an end-to-end verified system so
from the eye level like in the from the
eye level specification like we see here
to the more low level implementation we
need to take care of our property ok now
what are the challenges and then I
hopefully will answer Alan question what
are the challenges of verification for
for verification of differential privacy
I will sketch the mirror and then
possibly come back later so in general
if we look at this definition we have
something that is a bit more involved
than a some other property we
verification people are used to work
with so the first complication is that
when we reason about differential
privacy we are in some about these two
ideal world where we have a two database
the different one individual and this is
not something baking in our algorithm is
just the proof so we need to reason
about these two databases in some way
and we hope these relational reasoning
because we read
about the relation between two inputs
the two inputs different one individual
then there is a lot of probabilistic
reasoning which set aside differential
privacy from other setting and then
there is also a quantitative reasoning
because we need we know that we can
think about this parameter of the
definition of differential privacy as
some kind of budget and we need to
reason about this so we need a good
decomposition of our problem that
addresses this kind of properties
so now let's see what people have done
in this direction being a mini-course I
will present a work by many people in
the community I hope I will give the
good references but please stop me if
there is something unclear so the first
approach is designing a language which
guarantees differential privacy by
design now I think one of the reason why
people like got very excited about
differential privacy and I think we are
all aware of that is that it provides
some compositional method to reason
about application so for instance we
have what in general in the we can call
a sequential composition that say if we
ran multiple queries then and each one
of them is differentially private for
some parameter of epsilon then the
overall process can be consider the sum
of the parameter differentially private
of course this is the basic composition
of differential privacy we have a more
advanced composition where we I think
yes and we have science in some of them
before in the week where we have a
better use of the parameter but for my
talk I will not go into that now another
kind of composition that we have is what
we often refer to as a parallel
composition and this is often I think
this was this term was used by Frank in
his work on pink but I think in general
this principle is used a lot in
different analysis of differential
privacy and this idea that if we can
somehow create a partition of the data
and then we run differential query
differentially private queries on each
partition then the overall process is
mainly now we don't need to sum up the
parameter but we
and just take the maximum of the
parameter or rather like in this case if
I use the same parameter the overall
process is just Absalom differentially
now why these two composition are useful
because we can reason about a privacy as
a kind of budget and this is very
attractive this is one of the reason why
I think differential privacy was is very
attractive for several developer because
we can reason about the consumption of
privacy and we have a mathematical
calculus to do this based on this Sun
and Maxim now in this vision we also
have to be a bit careful because in
general is true that we can reason about
privacy as a privacy budget but we also
need to think about some basic component
and the privacy of this basic component
so composition is not everything we need
to start from somewhere now I think one
of the reasons why this is attractive is
that it avoid the really reasoning about
probabilities here there is no
probabilistic reasoning in the idea of
composing they probably the
probabilistic reasoning is confined to
the basic components and this is a very
useful and then is a kind of a general
way of reasoning because we can use
other composition other definition of
differential privacy and still we can
reason in this way yes
aren't you worried not so much about the
budgeting but also about the misuse of
this concept for example if a partition
the data best on just a ridiculous book
being closed so far in the very first
year sorry yeah yeah I should have said
that that so of course when then yes
yeah so that's a good point yeah these
are at the basic component that I was
saying in some senses so when you do
these partition if you have a primitive
for partition you have to guarantee that
the partition are independent from the
data now we are looking more at using
this concept later I will go more in the
in the boxes yes any other question okay
so how can we use these this idea so I
promised a bit more code that so let me
try to go a bit into more code than now
I want to I want to show how we can use
this principle on an example this is an
example I will use probably all along my
talk it's not if you are looking for an
algorithmic for good algorithmic idea
they are not here this is a very simple
example it's just based on composition
as I was saying before so what is this
example we want to mainly build the CDF
of some data and in general we can think
when we program it we can think that a
way to do this is to take a list of
bucket for which we want to compute the
CDF of each bucket what does it mean we
want to compute the number of record
with value less than the element in the
bucket so for instance in this case
we can say that the CDF of 2000 of 32
and CDF of 50 is 4 and build this now
how can we program these in a easy way
here it is
so let me try to walk you through this
code so here I use a bit is a bit less
low-level than the previous example
because I use a bit more what nowadays
we have available in many languages
which are some Combinator to do
filtering to do composition and so on
how can we interpret this so the CDF
first take two data so it takes the
database that I call DB and then the
list of buckets for which we want to
compute the CDF and then it returned
this should be a list of int of course I
didn't verified my own code and this is
why there will be many titles sorry this
is a a return a list of counting mainly
okay now the way we do this is we
iterate with a for loop through the list
of buckets and then for each element in
the bucket we take the database we count
by this this command we count how many
element in the data set are less than
the element in the bucket
now how should we interpret this here we
have two primitives the primitive where
that is a filtering it filter out the
element that are not less than the
bucket and then we use a count primitive
which count the resulting number of
element and then we accumulate these in
a list as I said and each one of these
is accountant then we return the list
okay now how can we build a private
version of CDF I will use an either way
so in the nays to do the CDF build the
list as before and then add in Laplace
noise to each element okay
this mainly use the idea of sequential
composition where we can guarantee that
we can guarantee that the overall
processes are differentially private and
if we add Laplace noise accordingly to
epsilon over and the number of buckets
we have that the overall process is
epsilon differentially private okay is
the algorithm
so I want to modify the code I show you
before that didn't have privacy to meet
this specification how can we do this so
one way to do this is exactly to add the
Laplace Musa to each counter so doing
account plus noise and the guaranty that
we have a deception on now
we want some system doing this for us
and this is what I will do next but
before going into that I want to show
you another kind of CDF that we can try
to build using parallel composition okay
parallel composition again we partition
the element without looking at the data
should not be based on the data and then
we run our differentially private
queries on the partitioning data so for
instance we can decide to partition our
data accordingly to the buckets in
different tables and then build the CDF
by summing some summing up the result
that we obtained okay so for instance if
I do the CDF of 30 I have to and now for
doing the CDF of 40 I will take these
two and I will son an additional element
that came from the second table for the
third I will do the sum of these two
plus the additional element here
so how can we do this we can do this for
instance by this program which has the
same input and output as before but now
what we do before our for loop is to
partition our dataset and now we assume
that M is already the partition a data
set where we also do the count and then
for each element with an as I was saying
before we sum the previous element plus
the additional count is this code okay
with everybody
okay all right so now what we can do
this private we can add Laplace to each
counter and then we can sum the result
of it all so these Laplace noise of
course here we will not have the same
result as in the previous one because we
are adding noise in a different way but
is still in approximate the CDF
so in particular we add the noise to
this counter and then we sum up them so
is the reason why I took this example is
to show you that we could do a similar
analysis using just the sequential
composition or using the parallel
composition now how can we support this
design how can we support this reasoning
about parallel and sequential
composition this was one of the first
language that was proposed in this
community for doing exactly this it was
the work by Frank on a pink and also I
mentioned the work by Batali's Matic of
groups on iRobot so Helen these are the
two of the name I you were asking about
of course a design known probably just
in this community or in a community
close to this that they are not used too
much outside but they try to achieve
this goal that is a building application
that are private by design
differentially private by design
I could stick that question were saying
so like these are sort of you know
algorithms with funny names like they
are like built on top of familiar
algorithms right if they're like related
to known languages like known languages
with like extra commands for private
yeah yeah one ideally would not have to
like learn the new language from scratch
it would be like that's that that is a
good point and is actually my first
point here so pink is not really and
maybe these hands were a bit too far
question before right so pink is not
design in isolation is designed inside
the C sharp which is a general-purpose
language and is we can think about it as
an API actually it's built on top of an
API that people have designed before for
data analysis which is a link this is a
or maybe more than that analysis I would
say like queries in the setting of
sql-like queries so it was the languages
that providing this primitive I'll show
you before like where count and so on to
support the design of SQL kind of
queries and the Frank extended it to
address differential privacy and it was
a bit the first language that was
designed and it was designed with
composition in mind so the principle it
provide is a really this principle about
composition so to conclude this first
part I would like to show you how we can
do our example in pink so and understand
the water the feature that pink provide
to address the correctness issue how
pink helped us design more correct
application so this is how this program
that I show you before the
differentially private CDF based on
sequential composition would look like
in pink so if you are a pink programmer
or a c-sharp a programmer you would
write
something like this I'd say something
like this because I change a bit some
part but overall this is the general
idea and what pink provided are some new
primitive like this pink agent budget
that help with tracking the privacy
budget so these for instance create a
new agent which is a responsible of
tracking the privacy budget to which we
give the budget and from now on every
time we will perform a query decision
this agent will take care of checking if
we have available budget and if not
we'll tell us you don't have a budget we
also need to provide mainly the data the
raw data to pink now I put this part in
this place but usually disease may be in
a separate part where is the
initialization of the of the application
so we create an agent that take care of
the privacy budget and the pink wearable
that takes care of the database and then
you wouldn't pass around at that point
you you wouldn't like pass around the
agent variable you just keep TV yes
so one thing exactly from now or yeah
from now on the only variable we will
use is this pretty bloody bit behind the
scenes is this agents track in the
budget exactly so in particular now you
see that a bright program very similar
to the one before that where instead of
using the database we use exactly this
private database and that take care for
us of the budgeting and we also use a
primitive noise count which mainly
perform at the addition of
of laplace noise but it does this in a
controlled way and that we call in
general DS transformation and this
aggregation because the first one
transform at the data set we can think
about it as changing the shape of the
data set for instance by filtering out
some element we get a smaller table and
then with this we aggregate D and this
is a the first example the second
example can be written in a very similar
way where the part that change is just
the one below we still have the pink
agent for the budget we have the private
data base and what we change is just
that we do a different kind of
transformation because now we do the
partition and then we do again the
aggregation okay
yes so what happens if you run out of
privacy budget so if you run out of
privacy budget and we will see a bit
later after the break
mainly the application tell you that you
run out and it will not as well anymore
query it will create an exception that
say privacy budget if I try to now
access privity be enough by like noisy
counter fire like something not right we
just come to it also owner yeah exactly
that's the whole idea so that once you
have these this kind of object now it
has this kind of object as an interface
that allow only some kind of operation
so you cannot do a regular count if you
want you need to do a noisy count you
cannot do so since now this is a
protected object we need to guarantee
that we do on the operation that are
alright so after they pose I will look
at little inside these boxes here and
then we will look at other methods
so if there's a couple quick questions
before the break that otherwise will
come back at 11:00
[Applause]
you